I'm tired of always having to deal with
the political mudslinging when it comes
to public shootings but that's the only
question of the day comment below I
genuinely want to hear from you do you
think that we should do the class act
just mourn those who lost as we usually
would have throughout human history or
are we beyond the point of can we no
longer afford that has the left forced
us to fight fire with fire do we have to
go tit for tat that's a question I
struggle with because a lot of times
we're looking old you're doing the same
thing well yeah I am but that's because
they're they're they're politicizing the
gun control issue before the bodies are
even close your hand every time Jared
you know what set a time we've already
done rebuttals with with Vox because
they had the biggest day and it's a gun
video for a while with the Young Turks
we've done videos out there on the
Second Amendment whether it's meant just
for muskets they did the same thing with
freedom of speech we've done the gun
show loophole we've done so many videos
we've done so many shows where we've
dealt with the Australian gun buyback
the Canadian gun laws that I grew up
with so you know what I'm not gonna
revisit let's recap it and then we'll be
done with it because I know you're
dealing with this on every single other
show we can run to why Elon Musk sucks
or something else because I'm tired of
the same conversation over and over set
your timer let's go assault weapons are
not an actual thing mass shootings are
on the decline the United States does
not actually have the most mass
shootings in the world all pistols are
some form of semi-automatic an ar-15 is
actually not a military weapon states
with the United States stricter gun
control laws and not statistically
reduced crime gun control matters at
large have actually proven to be not
effective in reducing violent crime the
United States by the way does not have
the highest violent crime rate in the
industrialized world most of the
statistical gun deaths that you actually
read about include suicides that's
something I didn't tell you gun by the
way gotta save millions more lives and
they ever take according to the FBI
anywhere from two hundred thousand to
three million plus by the way none of
this matters because the Second
Amendment ensures your right to
self-preservation period including
firearms period and yes that extends
beyond muskets to high-capacity guns
that were around back then like the
Pelton flintlock the public gun the
Peckham products revolver and by the way
your toll for exploiting this senseless
tragedy to try and forcibly strip us of
our human rights regardless okay on what
the show does that about cover it I
think that's a big pieces of human shape
if I could stand up and clap right less
than a minute that's pretty good you can
skip the entire CNN dialogue we've
covered all of that we've covered every
watch this AC were your reference mister
Internet
yep dick do some research guys then
yourself I'm so tired of the gun it
bothers me is that is the grandstanding
the political grandstanding the virtue
signaling is that they have the moral
high ground when their very position is
evil and I mean that is it no it's evil
to disarm law-abiding citizens what
people doesn't like what gives you the
right what who in the hell do you think
you are because someone did something
bad you think that you now have the
right to strip me of my god-given right
to self-defense that's the problem with
people countries like Europe sorry spend
computer that's the problem with
countries that don't recognize your
rights coming from somewhere else other
than government's sorry you get the
angry skeptic atheists mad and guess
what the Constitution recognizes it
rights were bestowed to us they were
bestowed upon us by God not by
government but these people don't
believe that they think they gave you
the rights that's why they think they
can take it away they think they can
tell you can't defend yourself because
something did something mean on a school
property you know what it's terrible and
it sucks and I wish we could just say
it's terrible and it sucks I knows we
could just say God what an awful tragedy
can't we warn as a nation and the left
talks about coming together and finding
common ground how about you find common
ground shut your mouth and let the
bodies be buried before you push bulk
legislation that you know won't do
anything and you don't even abide by by
yourself alright hey if you like this
clip you're like most of the Internet
you have a short attention span but it
was taken from the full show you can see
it in a box playing next to me that's
once a week on Thursdays full one and a
half hour show or you can join the mug
club for the daily show we have to take
some of that off YouTube because they're
monitoring us and censoring our words